Speaker 1: Let's hear from some people in the
audience. These are the most important people
without you there is no show. We take
calls via discord on the Friday show at
David Pacman dot com slash discord and we will
start today with Chris from Massachusetts. Chris
what is going on my friend?
Speaker 2:
Hi, Dave. It is so wonderful to finally be able
to speak with you. I have two quick questions that
actually don't have to do with politics and start.
Speaker 1: Sure, that's a load.
Speaker 2: First, I know that you are a fan of
tango music. Of course. I was wondering if you
are into any other forms of Latin American
music from other parts of the world. Do you
like salsa? Mariachi? Any of those?
Speaker 1: You know, I'm not huge on.
Let me put it this way. I like all of it. I
just don't know enough about it to be able
to name any artists. It's sort of like I know
when I go to certain restaurants or events,
they have music of all of these styles that
I like, but it's not like I take time out of
my day to go and investigate artists or
bands or anything like that. But sure,
I mean, listen, other than country and hardcore
heavy metal, I'll go for most stuff, you know?
Speaker 2: Oh, fantastic. Fantastic.
Thank you. And my last quick question is,
I look at the person with strong run
amigo Pedro in this colombiano No Nozick.
Speaker 1: El Paso. No, no.
Ms.. Shama. Ms.. Nunca Shama.
Speaker 2: I can hear into saying I loved him.
Speaker 1: He was the best. Chris asking What
happened to Pedro from Colombia? Yeah,
we just haven't heard from him. And
honestly, it feels like years. Chris.
Speaker 2: Oh, well, that's all I have
for you. Thank you so much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right, Chris from Massachusetts
with a number of questions in a number of
languages, and we love to see it. Let's
go to Harry from Chicago, Illinois. Harry
from Chicago, welcome to the David Pacman
Show. How may I serve you today, sir?
Speaker 2: Can you hear me? Yes. All
right. Excellent. So I used to call in as
Harry from Columbus. I don't know if you
have any recollection of that. I've
recently moved to Chicago. You know,
after some brief inspiration from you, actually.
Speaker 1: Wow. I know that you moved from
Columbus to Chicago because of something I said.
Speaker 2: In part. In part I wanted to move
anyway. But, you know, just some stuff
that you said really put me over the edge.
Speaker 1: And why Chicago did it?
Have I sung its praises before?
Speaker 2: No, I mean, not necessarily
Chicago so much as getting out of a red
state and going into a blue state.
Speaker 1: I got you, I think.
Are you enjoying that?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I am. Greatly I am.
I haven't driven on a highway in like two weeks
now. I think my brain is finally healing a little
bit. That's good. But it's been really good.
Speaker 1: Well, to any extent that you want
to thank me, I will accept the praise. Thank you.
Speaker 2: Well, I mean, I know you used to also
live in western Massachusetts,
is that correct? Yeah.
I went to college there. You know about Holyoke?
Speaker 1: Yes. Yes, I do.
Speaker 2: Okay. Did you
pronounce it Holyoke or Holyoke?
Speaker 1: No, no, no, I. You know, I'm not
into this whole Holyoke thing. I pronounce it
Holyoke. Now, remember, I'm from Argentina, and
I only lived in that region for a for a time. And
never in Holyoke, but I pronounce it Holyoke.
Speaker 2: Yeah. It takes time to learn the
language like Amherst and Holyoke. So my,
my question about politics, after, you know,
last week's rulings, all the bad SCOTUS rulings,
that in my opinion, of course. How do you feel
about SCOTUS? It's not. It's something that it
engages in. It specifically is judicial review.
Right. Ultimately determined in I think was
Marbury v Madison way back when that SCOTUS could
do this. Now, other countries, other democracies,
they don't have this kind of judicial review.
Do you consider it something bad? Do you think
more justices is the problem? People on the left
have criticized that. Yeah, I think judicial
review is needed to be a check and balance.
What do you what do you think about, you
know, judicial review of law that is passed?
Speaker 1: So, listen, obviously, I am
not a legal expert, so I speak to the
political implications here. I do believe that
there is a degree to which judicial review,
meaning the power of a court to say this law
that was passed no good, it's unconstitutional
to some degree. It can be undemocratic. The nine
justices are not elected and they can say, well,
we're overriding the popular sovereignty of states
and Bubba ba ba ba. Okay. But sometimes they may
be making the right decision and we might want it.
You can say judicial review is unreliable because
as you're pointing out, it depends to some degree
on personal views and biases. We know that a left
wing Supreme Court versus a right wing Supreme
Court is likely to come down in different places
on many important and controversial decisions.
You can argue that judicial review is unnecessary
in that there are better ways to protect certain
rights, either by referenda or media scrutiny or,
you know, but but at the same time, sometimes
you can't. There's the argument that it's
counterproductive because then when there's
judicial review that goes counter to the
party that is in power, there's a backlash effect
where the party in power says, all right, well,
we're going to now figure out some other way
to do the thing so that we can act like Biden
figuring out a different way to do student loans.
So I think that there are really good arguments
against judicial review. But where I am trying
to focus most based on my audience and what I do
is we we have to remember that if Hillary
Clinton had defeated Donald Trump, a lot of
what we have seen from this Supreme Court would
never have happened. It is undeniable at this
point. This is not to shame anybody. This is not
to insult anybody. I am doing a show that is based
around electoral politics. We have an election
coming up. We need to beat people over the head
metaphorically with the reality that we may again
have this sort of situation, depending on who wins
in November of 2024 and that everything that's
happened, the justices that are now on the court,
Roe v Wade, all of these different things. If
Hillary Clinton gets to put a few people on the
court instead of Donald Trump based on winning
in 2016, we have a completely different Supreme
Court. It's not a solution. It doesn't answer
a lot of these questions, but it's a reminder
about the importance of these elections.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree that I don't think
I don't have any delusions that judicial
review is going away anytime soon. And I
agree. If, you know, four out of nine of the
justices are, you know, were either stolen,
elected from presidents who didn't win the popular
vote, I agree that electoral wisdom is probably
the best way to beat them onto the SCOTUS, even
though in the 200 year history of our country,
it's been mostly a right wing institution that has
dominated us. You know, with all that in mind, we
can still hope. Thanks for taking my call, David.
Speaker 1: All right, Harry from Chicago,
great to hear from you. Just a reminder for
people waiting to chat with me. You must have
your name and location and your nickname
if you just have one or the other or just
a nickname or that sort of thing, you are not
going to be called on it. Sort of just like,
can folks follow basic directions?
We're trying to have some filter,
so we try to get quality calls. So we do
we do enforce that. We do enforce that.